notre invité politique ce matin un petit
accident de Verdon on va réparer ça
merci Olivier Marley bonjour député
d'arrêter leur président du groupe les
républicains à l'Assemblée nationale on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Christelle
Bertrand du groupe La Dépêche bonjour
votre frère bonjour Oriane bonjour
Olivier marlex bonjour on commence par
ce qu'il s'est passé hier en Pologne et
ce missile qui est tombé en Pologne
missile d'origine indéterminée la France
Emmanuel Macron appelle ce matin à la
plus grande prudence sur l'origine de ce
tien est-ce que vous demandez à
Elisabeth borne de réunir les présidents
de groupe ou de s'exprimer rapidement
devant le Parlement pour dire ce qu'il
en est de ce que va faire la France
qui qui interpelle donc désir soir un
modèle gouvernement de s'exprimer de
dire la forme l'Assemblée nationale
informée bon voilà pour l'instant pas de
pas plus de de précision on préférerait
tous que ce soit des débris d'un d'une
contre-mesure
ukrainienne qu'un missile rue sur la on
attend des en tout cas évidemment je
suis tout seul beaucoup d'intérêts
personne n'a envie de voir une
escalade dans ce dans ce conflit et donc
voilà on préférerait la première option
à débris à débris Ukrainiens à un
missile russe et vous demandez encore
Élisabeth bande de s'exprimer
ses déclarations de la République et le
gouvernement tiennent des Français
informés la Pologne est un pays membre
de l'Union européenne
membre de l'OTAN et donc évidemment s'il
s'agissait d'une agression extérieure
sur la des conséquences évidemment grave
qu'il faudrait qu'il faudrait arriver à
gérer intelligemment on va parler de la
politique migratoire et après les
premiers examens des dossiers des
migrants de l'océan Viking Gérald
Darmanin a annoncé hier devant les
députés couloir expulser 44 migrants que
pensez-vous de cette décision c'est du
grand gribouille cette petite la réalité
c'est que le gouvernement a cédé ce que
ce que tout le monde depuis 10 ans c'est
des bateaux qui se courent entre
guillemets des migrants Méditerranée ça
fait 10 ans depuis le Lampedusa 2011 que
ce phénomène existe ça fait 10 ans que
la France résistait même Emmanuel Macron
avait jusqu'à présent refusé
d'accueillir l'Aquarius qui est l'ancien
nom de la chaîne Viking aujourd'hui on a
la réalité c'est qu'on a ce qu'on a cédé
donc de redomontas de les gesticulations
de Monsieur Darmanin ne on passe ce
renoncement renoncement qui est tragique
parce qu'il envoie un signal au réseau
de passeur la réalité derrière tout ça
c'est que les réseaux qui qui organisent
enfin c'est que les bateaux qui se font
du sauvetage en Méditerranée le fond à
la frontière des autoritoriales des
réseaux de passeurs qui sont des réseaux
criminels
mettent des des migrants sur des bateaux
des canaux pneumatiques de préférence
enfin des embarcations de très précaires
et appelle les secours dès qu'ils sont
la limite des autres territoriales alors
on parle de réseau de réseau mafieux qui
qui abusent de de la misère de la misère
humaine et donc d'une manière ou d'une
autre se rendre complice avec tout ça et
absolument
des passeurs pour vous aujourd'hui
deviennent quasiment vous avez un
rapport de Frontex qui est extrêmement
précis sur ce sujet sur le fait que il y
a une forme de complicité qui s'est
installée
il faut une action beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus résolue que celle
d'ailleurs première chose qu'on demande
on a déposé une proposition de
résolution à l'Assemblée nationale pour
d'abord demander au gouvernement de
s'associer à l'initiative qu'on prise
les pays et les périgres Méditerranée
les pays membres de l'Union européenne
riverains de la Méditerranée l'Italie la
Grèce Chypre et Malte qui demande à
l'Union européenne de se saisir du sujet
se saisir du sujet ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que le sauvetage en
Méditerranée il doit être fait par il
doit être fait par Frontex et par
personne d'autre et pas par défiance ONG
qui ont parfois une intention de de
d'encourager finalement ces mouvements
sinon le port le plus Sud le plus sûr le
plus proche puisque c'est ça la règle en
sauvetage sauvetage en mer si on ramène
les gens sur le port sur le plus proche
ils sont ils sont sur la côte d'Afrique
du Nord il y a eu de nombreux porteurs
où les gens auraient pu être déposés
notamment notamment Bizerte ou ou enfin
donc on est sur des gens qui nous
intentions ces ONG on a un rôle douteux
et on voudrait que ce soit Frontex qui
fasse ça on voudrait que Frontex gère
des hotspots pour accueillir ces
migrants y compris sur les côtes
africaines et on voudrait aussi que
l'Union européenne discute sérieusement
tout ça avec l'Union africaine l'aide au
développement des pays membres de
l'Union et de l'Union européenne c'est
plus de 20 milliards par an quand vous
donnez 20 milliards par an à des pays
africains vous êtes en droit de demander
qui prennent un petit peu leur
responsabilité dans la gestion de ces
flux de migrants pour l'instant ce n'est
pas le cas donc il faut vraiment que
l'Union européenne change de braquet
puisque clairement c'est un sujet sur
lesquels on a besoin de coopération
entre les pays de membres de l'Union
européenne un dernier mot sur les ONG il
faut arrêter les subventions publiques
envers ces ONG Vous demandez ça aussi
oui son décohérents et si on a mis en
place une action résolue avec Frontex on
n'a plus besoin des ONG pour le faire en
tout cas pas pour ce rôle là que des ONG
aille gérer des camps d'accueil dans les
pays du Maghreb très bien mais kenzaille
mettre leur énergie à lutter contre les
passeurs très bien mais pas pour faire
son travail là la police des frontières
devrait être faite par exemple qui sont
attribués aux eng pardon et ça veut dire
conditionner les aides qui sont
attribuées aux ONG oui bien sûr bien sûr
et puis je mange mais générale
j'aimerais qu'il y a beaucoup plus de
transparence sur le financement des des
ONG d'ailleurs
plus au-delà de des ONG comme
dans la vie dans la vie publique de
beaucoup de choses qui influent sur le
débat public toujours à travers un côté
bon sentiment d'ailleurs et en mettant
ça en avant en essayant de de toucher
les gens on a vu les conséquences sur le
sur le nucléaire la France a renoncé au
nucléaire de l'un des seuls pays au
monde à l'avoir fait parce qu'on a des
ONG qui nous expliquaient nucléaire
c'était très très mal en réalité ça
n'aimait pas de CO2 et donc c'est une
énergie qui est une richesse vous
souhaitez un meilleur encadrement
comment ça peut se passer on a interdit
aux partis politiques de recevoir des
dons des financements d'entreprise pour
pas qu'il y ait de collusion entre les
intérêts privés les intérêts publics au
nom de quoi autorise-t-on les ONG qui
prétendent défendre une espèce de morale
de de morale publique d'être en réalité
parfois le phone est d'intérêt
d'intérêts privés d'intérêt privé
étrangers moi je souhaite qu'évidemment
mettre bon ordre regardez exactement
regarde mais regardez un exemple très
simple la ministre de l'Énergie belge
suivi ce détail
anti-nucléaire la Belgique est un pays
qui a des centrales nucléaires ministre
de l'énergie qui milite contre le
nucléaire
demande la fermeture des centrales on
découvre qu'elle est avocate et que son
principal client c'est gastrophe on
découvre que Monsieur Schroeder
ancien chancelier allemand devient
administrateur de gastrom donc oui il y
a un mélange d'intérêt public et privé
qui se fait qui est qui est absolument
détestable on souhaite combattre par
tous ces mélanges d'intérêt pourquoi pas
donc l'autoriser les ONG qui s'occupent
des migrants pour être le bras armé de
certains intérêts que l'on ignore
aujourd'hui je connais pas le
financement en tout cas il faut
clarifier tout ça
ouais l'un des candidats à la présidence
des LR a pour sa part demander
l'interdiction du voile dans l'espace
public dans les espaces publics est-ce
un point de consensus chez les LR
dans ce que vous en pensez
de commenter tous les sujets aujourd'hui
toutes les idées avancées par par les
uns et les autres parce que ça divise
pardon parce que ça divise dans votre
camp non mais je pense que enfin ce
sujet je suis pas sûr qu'il soit sur la
table en ce terme enfin voilà je peux
rentrer dans les dans tous les débats
on a des espaces du service public on
est des cas on est d'accord pour
l'interdiction dans des espaces du
service public j'ai faisons déjà
respecté l'interdiction du voile dans
des espaces service public battons-nous
aujourd'hui
pour le respect pour le respect de la
laïcité dans les établissements
scolaires c'est ça l'actualité c'est ça
l'urgence après les propositions des uns
et des autres les laisser dans leur
cadre
dans leur cadre de campagne électorale
voilà on va parler d'une question qui
inquiète les Français c'est le pouvoir
d'achat c'est aujourd'hui la réduction
de la ristourne à la pompe restante du
gouvernement restant de Total vous aviez
plaider pour cette fameuse ristourne de
centimes vous regrettez que le
gouvernement la baisse
vous savez que les Français font en
moyenne horribles de France 20 km par
jour pour aller travailler au parc d'une
moyenne ça faisait des gens qui
malheureusement dans mon rural sont
obligés de faire beaucoup plus et donc
dès qu'on va avoir un carburant qui va
remonter à 2 €, ça va être le cas quand
la richtone ne sera plus là évidemment
ça va poser des problèmes terribles de
pouvoir d'achat
parce que vous êtes aussi très sensible
elle a coûté 800 millions sur sur
les républicains avaient demandé sa mise
en place au mois de au mois de juillet
donc voilà parce que vous voulez une
mesure qui bénéficie à tout si on
voulait pas d'une mesure chèque
supplémentaire quelle les gens savent
pas s'ils ont droit pas droit
et qui en général les données que gens
qui ne travaillent pas donc ça va pas
beaucoup de ça pas beaucoup de sens
voilà moi j'avertis une
erreur pour pour nos compatriotes et
j'avertis la première ministre que que
ce serait probablement insoutenable
d'ailleurs si le gouvernement enfin ça
va dépendre des cours du baril
si on a de nouveau après de l'essence à
la pompe autour de 2 euros avec
d'ailleurs au passage un état qui est
celui qui qui gagne le plus d'argent sur
tout ça puisque je rappelle que plus de
la moitié du prix de l'essence à la
pompe ce sont des taxes donc il est
absolument scandaleux que ce soit l'état
qui qui s'enrichissent sur le dos des
Français et donc la ristourne c'était
une façon de restituer aux Français leur
argent
reste durablement à des niveaux
inacceptables pour les Français autour
de 2 euros il faudra bien que le
gouvernement prenne sa responsabilité et
retrouve une mesure qui concerne tout le
monde
autre sujet c'est le budget de la
Sécurité sociale votez hier par le Sénat
on va en parler pour elle modifié dans
ce cadre là le Sénat votait un
amendement qui repousse l'âge de départ
à la retraite à 64 ans Elisabeth
borgnère à l'assemblée a laissé entendre
qu'elle pourrait que la majorité
pourrait soutenir cette amendement à
l'Assemblée c'est une bonne nouvelle
selon vous
le gouvernement vote pas dans le Sénat
votre cet amendement tous les tous les
ans d'une façon de réaffirmer sa
position il a un peu modifié d'ailleurs
en appelant le gouvernement en faisant
plutôt une feuille de route pour pour la
négociation nous ce qu'on veut c'est
d'abord que le temps de la négociation
ait lieu j'en a beaucoup rapproché à
Emmanuel Macron de ne pas respecter les
corps intermédiaires dans le précédent
mandat de ne pas respecter le Parlement
ce serait c'est pas nous qui allons le
demander de ne pas respecter les
partenaires sociaux
c'est une feuille de route c'est
vraiment une feuille de route c'est
vraiment notamment un amendement cet
amendement voté par les sénateurs
rappelle plusieurs choses je rappelle
que il y a la question de l'âge qui est
à condition sinequanone parce que en
clair c'est la seule chose qui permet
d'augmenter retraite je crois que c'est
le but ultime de la réforme c'est de
pouvoir augmenter les retraites qui sont
trop bas sur notre pays
je suis parti de ceux qui militent pour
que y ait il n'y ait pas de retraite
inférieure à
85% du du SMIC entre 1100 et 1200 euros
il faut qu'il faut que mais si on veut
pouvoir faire quelque chose qui a les
critères de l'âge mais il y a pas que la
question de l'âge il y a d'autres sujets
il y a évidemment automatiquement les
carrières longues plus vous entrez plus
vous reculez l'âge plus il faut tenir
compte des gens qui sont rentrés plutôt
sur le marché du travail ça peut les
carrières longues c'est la droite qui a
inventé ça lors de la réforme Fillon il
y a la question du de la fin de carrière
d'un sujet je pense qui peut faire
consensus chez les Français les Français
ils peuvent admettre de travailler un
peu plus longtemps à condition que
au-delà d'un certain âge il puisse
commencer à lever le pied et donc ça se
discute avec les partenaires sociaux va
être étudié en séance à l'Assemblée
nationale qu'est-ce qui va se passer
votre journée le gouvernement
globalement a dit qu'il respecterait les
partenaires
son calendrier qui insulte de
négociation avec les partenaires sociaux
et que le gouvernement me mettrait
sa propre feuille de route au terme de
concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux au début de l'année prochaine
donc je n'imagine pas seulement d'appel
du budget à un moment d'appel c'est fait
pour rappeler au gouvernement quelles
sont les thèmes de la de la négociation
ce que je viens de ce que je viens
d'évoquer les carrières longues la
pénibilité les fins de carrière le
cumulon pour retraite voilà ce qui est
sur la table après c'est au gouvernement
de respecter le dialogue dans une
situation un peu compliquée
avec Gérard Larcher et Bruno Retailleau
ce Sénas cet amendement il veut être
tous les ans depuis 5 ou 6 ans
réforme des retraites on est d'accord
pour dire qu'il y a un sujet réforme des
retraites on est d'accord pour dire que
la question de l'âge est un des critères
un report de l'âge légal de départ à 64
65 ans les républicains
du coup pour le coup sans doute pas
jusqu'à 65 ans brutalement
il faut surtout pas donner il faut
surtout pas non mais c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe il faut surtout pas
donner le sentiment mais c'est un
ensemble de choses pas bien un sujet moi
qui me choque beaucoup c'est que le
gouvernement dit qu'il ne touchera pas
au régime spéciaux voilà donc comment
est-ce que le gouvernement peut dire aux
Français je vous mets travailler tous un
peu plus sauf une question je leur
demande de rien on va appliquer la cause
du grand-père c'est à dire que ça
s'appliquera il y en a qui ont déjà été
réformés donc cela effectivement il y a
plus rien à faire la droite a fait mais
voilà vous pouvez pas dire ça en
français à la RATP
oui mais c'est tout ça déjà été modifié
en réalité donc pour le pour les autres
on est sur la clause du grand-père c'est
à dire qu'il se passe rien avant 40 ans
voilà je pense que ce serait
incompréhensible pour les Français
première question de sécurité puisque
vous examinez en ce moment la loi de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur qui était voté ici au Sénat
que les députés les républicains la
voteront aussi
notera l'examen du texte il a commencé
juste avant-hier ça fait deux jours
seulement de séance quoi en fait ce
qu'il y a dans texte ne pose pas de
problème ce qui ne pose problème c'est
tout ce qui n'est pas dans le texte
propose 15 milliards de plus pour les
forces de l'ordre dans les dans les
années qui viennent donc on est
forcément favorable à ça voilà après le
vrai sujet c'est tout ce qui n'est pas
notamment on a on a on a rien sur la
réponse pénale le vrai sujet aujourd'hui
allez je vais le dire franchement je
pense que c'est plutôt la question des
des moyens des forces de l'ordre elle
reste importante et de la modernisation
à faire il y a de l'équipement
évidemment ça mais je pense que
fondamentalement c'est c'est la réponse
pénale parce que ce que les ce que les
gendarmes et les policiers ne supportent
plus c'est d'interpeller des des des
petits ou grands voyous et que et que
automatiquement ils sont remis en
liberté c'est ça qui est insupportable
c'est ça qui fait perdre de l'énergie
qui perd du temps qui perdent des
mouvements
qui malheureusement n'est pas dans le
texte donc on a écrit au premier en
disant bon ce texte ok mais on attend un
texte sur la réforme pénale un peu
énergique et puis et aussi sur
l'immigration et aussi sur l'immigration
on a absolument rien mais il y a un
sujet sur lequel enfin je pense qu'il
est qui est majeur c'est l'expulsion des
étrangers délinquance
le Gouvernement arrête de saucissonner
et de promettre que que ce qu'il y aura
de mieux va arriver plus tard et on sait
pas quand donc
voilà on est plutôt
intéressé par ce texte on va demander de
durcir quelques dispositions voilà mais
sincèrement il réglera pas grand chose
on attend un texte sur l'immigration en
revanche extrêmement ambitieux
difficulté du rassemblement national on
présentait une proposition de loi contre
les rodeurs on sait que c'est un sujet
de qui est prêt à coeur par les par les
républicains cette proposition de loi du
RN autoriserait les forces de l'ordre à
aller au contact des délinquants et
triplerait les peines encourus vous
pourriez la voter
faut pas être en permanence dans
l'assurance chien surtout le problème de
rodéo urbain c'est que déjà ça fait des
dégâts et que malheureusement vous avez
j'en ai eu dans des cas dans ma
circonscription à Dreux je me souviens
d'une d'une petite fille cadidja qui est
décédé dans le cadre de urbain donc vous
savez pas en plus demandé aux policiers
devenir rajouter du foutoir en
tamponnant les véhicules dans ce cadre
là voilà je ne suis pas d'ailleurs
contre une réflexion sur les moyens
d'interception en cas de refus
d'obtempérer mais c'est c'est un autre
sujet un autre sujet c'est le refus
d'obtempérer on a vu on a vu aussi le le
drame d'un policier qui a ouvert le feu
et malheureusement a fait une victime
dans le véhicule qui visiblement n'était
pas pour grand-chose donc
nationale sur les rôles de urbain
aujourd'hui de mesure qui ont été votés
déjà par législateur qui paraît
tellement de confisquer des véhicules
c'est une mesure extrêmement extrêmement
puissante en général on a de la
vidéoprotection on sait identifier les
véhicules on peut les confisquer et puis
6 points de retrait sur les permis de
conduire c'est pas totalement non plus
anecdotique
oui sur les énergies renouvelables en
texte qui arrive bientôt dans
l'hémicycle les sénateurs n'ont
finalement pas voté de droits de veto
pour les maires concernant la
construction d'éoliennes vous vous y
êtes plutôt favorable c'est un nouveau
point de divergence avec vos camarades
du Sénat
des points de divergence ils ont ils ont
voté ils ont voté à dispositif qui est
un peu un peu alambiqué à mon goût quoi
c'est à dire j'ai essayé de faire de la
planification et de de dire qu'il y
avait à droite veto un peu global voilà
bon ce texte il est très cafouillé
on n'y comprend pas grand chose donc on
devrait revenir à des choses simples
puisqu'en fait il y a des zones
d'implantation prioritaires puis il y a
des zones malgré tout on pourrait faire
donc oui je pense qu'il faut de manière
plus simple remettre un droit de veto un
droit de veto des mers sur sur les
implantations de moi je trouve assez ce
texte tous les projets
se concernant aujourd'hui dans une crise
de l'énergie telle qu'on aurait jamais
imaginé enfin les Français découvrent de
manière absolument stupéfaite que cet
hiver il pourra peut-être pas se allumer
la lumière dans le pré on la République
nous a promis la startup nation et on se
retrouve à la chandelle cet hiver on
décompte dans quel pays la France enfin
c'est un c'est un juin 40 énergétique en
réalité et de la seule réponse que
propose le gouvernement aujourd'hui au
lieu de réparer ses erreurs au lieu de
décider à la réparer de réparer
durablement pour l'avenir c'est de dire
bah oui on va faire des éoliennes
pourquoi alors pourquoi des éoliennes
pourquoi pas de la géothermie les
géothermie par exemple en France en
terme de est utilisé par beaucoup de nos
compatriotes mais elle ne l'est pas sur
des réseaux de réseaux de chaleur urbain
c'est pourquoi pourquoi alors le
gouvernement vous dit bah c'est parce
qu'on a pas un industriel qui nous
propose de solution alors qu'il y en a
partout en Europe partout dans le monde
donc en fait en France le gouvernement
nous explique qu'il fait ce que les
lobbystes lui demandent de faire et en
l'occurrence les les promoteurs
d'éoliennes Allemands sont visiblement
la porte ouverte au ministère de
l'écologie donc il ne sait faire que ça
c'est absolument désastreux moi
j'aimerais qu'on travaille sérieusement
sur les géothermie et sur beaucoup sur
l'hydroélectricité où il y a le plus
nouveau des où il y a de nouveau des
possibilités voilà beaucoup de et sur le
nucléaire évidemment un mot sur la
corrida puisque c'est un soleil
républicains vont devoir prendre
position l'interdiction de la corrida
qui sera examinée dans l'hémicycle la
semaine prochaine quel sera la position
des républicains sur ce texte
contre la proposition
d'Aymeric Caron la corrida ceux qui
critiquent le plus à corrida sont en
général des gens qui n'ont pas vu de
corrida qui en regard totalement
extérieur
très ému du rôle du du picador ou des
banderies en réalité des banderies c'est
un hameçon c'est interdire la pêche si
on va par là
la broderie il y avait une position
commune du groupe alerte sur cette
question
c'est la liberté de vote
mais je pense que j'ai républicain on
est attaché à ce qui est un élément de
patrimoine culturel dans le sud de la
France
au fil de cette entretien on a noté
quelques points de divergence chez au
sein de votre groupe
on sent quand même qu'au sein du groupe
c'est un peu compliqué que votre rôle
est un peu compliqué pour trouver des
points de convergence comment vous vous
gérez
c'est totalement pardon c'est totalement
faux oui la différence c'est que vous
avez d'un côté les petits soldats de
Monsieur Macron qui sont élus avec
Monsieur Macron sur l'affiche vous avez
des petits on nous appelait à
l'Assemblée pas très c'est pas très
gentil on appelait les Playmobil vous
avez maintenant les petits soldats
tournent Marine Le Pen qui votent
systématiquement comme Marine Le Pen
redemande nous nous sommes encore de
vrais parlementaires de vrais députés
élus pour représenter les citoyens de
nos circonscriptions et ce qui fait la
richesse du travail parlementaire pardon
de le répéter ici sur le plateau de
Public Sénat où ça devrait être une
évidence c'est que le député représente
les Français et qui soient pas juste les
pions des partis politiques c'est
insupportable si c'est ça qu'on veut
pour la démocratie je pense que c'est
très grave donc nous on représente les
après on va monter Français dans leur
diversité dans la diversité des
conditions de vie sur nos territoires la
vie elle est pas la même quand on est
quand on est quand on vit à Paris dans
le sixième arrondissement où nous sommes
aujourd'hui quand on vit chez moi à
Dreux à 80 km ou faut faire 50 km pour
aller travailler il est pas question
utiliser une trottinette suite à
l'électrique ou qu'on vous êtes en un
département de montagne c'est juste de
moyenne montagne comme le Massif central
ou d'autres montagnes comme la Savoie
aujourd'hui
est élu il rejoindront la majorité
présidentielle
sur votre plateau pour pour me dire que
c'était faux si je me suis trompé mais
je connais aucun député très des
républicains
enchaîné l'ancienne épouse d'Erik
sottier avec cumulée plusieurs emplois
lorsqu'elle était sa collaboratrice à
temps partiel à l'Assemblée elle aurait
été un peu au conseil départemental des
Alpes-Maritimes qu'il dirigeait à la
mairie de Nice de Christian Estrosi
erikiotti a fait un communiqué hier pour
dire que certains de ses emplois étaient
occupés successivement et que ça n'a
jamais dépassé le cumuler autorisé
comment vous réagissez à ces révélations
est-ce que c'est de nature à comprendre
je lis un enchaîné le jour il sort la
réponse que vous venez de me lire de la
part d'Éric chétie je pense est assez
clair
voilà je prends je crois me souvenir que
que rencontrait sa compagne quand elle
était déjà une collaboratrice je crois
monsieur à la présidente
on a le droit aussi on a le droit quand
on est dans le secteur public d'avoir
aussi
de rencontrer des
compagnes ou un compagnon qui soit qui
travaille dans le secteur public j'ai
sinon où est-ce que vous allez
rencontrer voilà les luttes de votre
cœur si vous ne rencontrez pas
sur le cadre de votre travail donc
est-ce que vous allez demander à le
recevoir pour qu'il s'explique sur ce
sujet parce que si jamais
quand vous dites que qui a aucune qui a
aucun élément contestable en droit je
vois pas je ne vois pas a priori où est
le sujet quoi
merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
Christelle à une de la dépêche elle est
retraite on en parlait la nouvelle piste
de la réforme c'est à la Une de votre
journal merci beaucoup avec notre invité
on passe au club de territoire